this is a weird moment right
because we did set visits together yeah
and round taes and everything else and
and uh and now you are on the other side
it was very weird so I I'm so curious um
what did you because you've been where
I'm sitting and now you're at Blum House
and you're in the machine you know how
the the cookies are made what has really
surprised you that you didn't really
expect sitting on this side that you now
learned being over there oh that is a
great question um how hard it is to make
a movie man like honestly like I
feel when I was in the world of
Journalism and when I was running the
website and working for fangoria I knew
it was difficult to make a movie but I
didn't know how truly hard it was to
make a movie like to get it off the
ground to you know be waiting over a
weekend for a cast to read it and hope
that they're going to be involved um
from getting onet and discovering all
the hurdles that they can that you could
be thrown like there's so many people
that work on a movie and they're all
putting their heart and soul into it and
so when I look back at like maybe
something I had written in fangoria like
a review or something and I was like man
I was really tough on this because I bet
they had a difficult time making like I
can look at a movie now and go I bet
this scene was incredibly tough to pull
off because of this this and this and
listen like it all starts with story if
the story is not great then you know
that that's that's an inherent problem
but uh it's just more respect for
everybody on the other side of the
camera you know behind the camera I
should say like there's just so much
hard work it's so many incredibly
talented people that are just rolling up
their sleeves getting in there believing
in your story and that's the thing we
like we love we love people who are you
know volunteering to tell a scary story
and I've I've equated it to like kind of
putting on a Carnival like we're all
people that are there going from town to
town bringing this show and bringing the
talent and we're all putting up the
tents and rolling out the you know all
everything and and and hopeful we all
hope that the audience loves it you know
and even if they don't it's like I still
reflect on everybody who put in their
hard work and I still respect all of
that they're incredible you've been at
Blum House now I want to say six years I
could be wrong about that number eight
years I apologize what is the thing that
you've been is there a project or two
projects this whole time you've been
like we've got to make this we've made
them that's what yeah we've made them I
mean like Halloween was a huge one uh
and I would say it's a balance
between uh it would be it would be a
balance between free freaky and happy
death day because obviously I'm a huge
slasher movie fanatic um I'm a huge
slasher movie fanatic and to see twists
on the slasher movie formula I've never
seen before uh Groundhog Day meets
Friday the 13th and then a body swap
horror movie like I just I loved both of
those and obviously I love Chris Landon
one of the things about the movie is it
reminds me that I'm never going to get
in a pool and I will never get in the
ocean I learn I learned this from a
young age from horror movies so what did
you what horror movie hit you as a kid
or horror movies hit you was a kid that
actually changed what you do in real
life my relationship to the water or or
just like in in general like Poltergeist
for me and under my bed interesting yeah
listen I think um I've always said that
horror movies are great uh learning
lessons forget school like horror movies
horror movies were my life lessons don't
go creeping Into the Woods at night you
know like something a movie like uh
Something Wicked This Way Comes you know
where these kids have full accessibility
to the town and they discover awful
things about the town they discover this
guy rolls into their place um you know
Jaws was a huge one obviously you know
when it comes to the
ocean uh yeah I'm trying to think I have
like really like Cujo sure Kujo I love
dogs I have dogs I had a dog or I have
one dog now but Kujo was like okay don't
go messing around with stray dogs or
don't go messing around with dogs you
don't know um you know there was just
that's a really great question because I
just think like I think everything about
horror has into this day still
inherently makes me cautious about
society and life everything everything
I've seen in a horror movie I inherently
am on edge and I'm oh and that's not
like I'm like a stress ball it's just
like oh I'm more attuned if I'm In This
Crowd scenario I'm more attuned I'm
looking for exits like I know you know
oh yeah
exactly
falling fallings I I don't think you've
announced I don't think blumo announced
it so um but when is there going to be
like a Five Nights at Freddy's I'm
assuming it made so much money movie
made so much money it was a huge success
and we're grateful for that and EM must
just such a great job but uh still
waiting for the green light on that you
know we'll see which is crazy yeah yeah
no it's not crazy it's just part of the
process I think yeah sure I just I just
I am surprised that there hasn't been a
date of like you know
7225 on a sequel movie that did that
well on both streaming and in theaters
right right I'm sure Jason's got some
tricks up his sleeve right exactly it's
just a question of when so um Megan was
a huge hit black phone was a huge hit
both are getting sequels um and we have
more fault so what when uh when do you
actually start shooting those have you
seen scripts that you're happy with um
haven't seen uh no listen like Megan
Megan 2 is underway not we haven't
started shooting or anything that uh
we're aiming towards that January
release date that was that was Set uh
and black phone 2 but there's nothing
else I could say really in terms of
movement sure is it one of these things
I mean a switch what are you excited
about at Plum housee that you're getting
ready to film in 2024 that maybe is not
on people's Radars um I will say that
one of the projects that I'm active on
is dead by daylight uh which is the
video game at a of the game that's been
around for like seven years um I look at
that as the kind
of uh celebration of horror that the
video game itself is and what we've
learned from Five Nights at Freddy's is
obviously you know Steer towards the
fans and obviously uh make a video game
adaptation for the fans I'm a huge dead
by daylight fan I played even though I
steered to like newer games like all
wake 2 and I'm like let me play some Al
2 tonight I'm going to get into dead by
daylight and play the killer tonight um
that one I'm super excited about and you
know kind of we're creatively mulling
around what the way into it is one
listen I love IMAX in the large scream
format and one of the things that I have
not really seen is horror or genre films
really embrace the large screen format
but you look at what Oppenheimer did
like the billion dollars and just how
much people love the big like that
screen is there any talk with you guys
about what can we do with IMAX or you
know to push the boundaries in a movie
theater um I mean we've had releases in
iMac obviously some of the Halloween
entries were in IMAX to shoot IMAX I
don't know if that's conducive to the
kind of the blumhouse system in a way
it's very expensive obviously um what
we'd prefer is give uh I mean at least
this is from my my standpoint is I'd
rather give that money to the filmmaker
so they can execute on the story and the
scares and make the scares scary as
possible also it's interesting I mean
like I wonder how that
would wonder how that would be
interpreted on a big big screen you know
I feel like if you're looking all over
you know it's just because scares are
very scientific in a way you know in
terms of how you orchestrate and or or
how you choreograph when things are
coming on camera you know um I'm
fascinated by it but I just don't know
if budgetarily it would work you know no
100 100% on that note sir I am really
happy for you thanks and it's really
good great interview thank you so good
to see you I was very excited when I saw
you on the
list